hello everyone we are ready to start
thursday evening lecture and as the
title says
we're going to look at the today at the
2014 us
chess championship games and i have
prepared two games to show you
and those both games are very tough ones
so we're gonna have one long stream
let me showing you this two games okay
instead of splitting it
so we're gonna start out with the game
against
grand master gareth okay grave was
very very hot uh in 2013 2012
2014 his rating as you can see was
slightly higher than me
and he was just playing some really
strong chats winning a lot of
tournaments
so uh i'm playing with the black pieces
so let's begin
he played d4 and so far the tournament
hasn't been gone
that well for me i was getting a little
frustrated because
i was let's say four highest radio
player in the tournament
there was kamsky honest joe goreev and
me
but i had four draws and some of them
against the lower end opponents
so i was certainly getting a little bit
frustrated with the uh
locker wins let's put it this way so
against gareth
i knew he was one of the toughest
opponents in the tournament so i had to
be
you know with black i had to be a little
bit careful
so he played knight c3 so he he's he
basically says with this move order
he basically says i'm ready for your
nimzo
so i can play the bishop before names or
i can play d5
so i i chose to play i chose to play the
move d5
now it takes i take back with the pawn
and now we have a queen's gambit
declined
okay so i play c6
and let me open up the youtube so i can
see it one second on my phone
so that way let's see here
all right there we go so guys if you
have any questions just put it in the
chat
and i'll be happy to answer your
questions okay so now
he played queen c2 knight play queen c2
he's trying to develop his pieces i play
bishop e7
now he played e3 uh standard position
i play knight bd7 h3
this is somewhat a little bit of a
surprising move
he played because you would expect
uh something like bishop d3 here
or knight f3 one of these two options
but this move came as a little surprise
looks like he
maybe prepared this and he's got an idea
behind it at some point he wants to
retreat to f4 with the bishop
to try to keep it in general h3 it's a
pretty useful move
in this position okay
now i played knight e4 i thought okay
since he's not really fighting for the
center immediately
let me try to use this move to uh
simplify the position a little bit
he played bishop f4 to my surprise i i
thought okay if he takes only seven
i just go queen e7 and his h3 move looks
kind of unclear
okay his h3 move
looks kind of unclear so that's why he
plays bishop f4
and okay i can if i want to be really
aggressive i can maybe even play the
move f5 but you always have to
you know you know calculate what would
happen if you place bishop d3
like this and then knight f3 so there's
always
an idea here so i didn't want to do that
so i say i will play bishop d6 i will
try to exchange
and now if he takes only four
i take he takes back
queen e7
and pinning the knight and the pawn
structure is split here
so it looks uh
very tricky for him like for example if
he plays bishop d3
uh bishop d3 i can take
so he takes i have the move f5
attacking the bishop
so
that's why he didn't do that he just
took knight takes the six i think i'm
i'm absolutely fine now after this
exchange
now he plays here and here i should uh i
should play like a
normal knight f6 move and then perhaps
try to even prepare g6 bishop f5 i had
to trade the bishops
but here i made a quick move and i
immediately regretted it
okay so i played a move
queen g5
putting pressure on g2
and now i thought oh now
he has to react to it you know he has to
do something
in my opinion but um
he actually has a very good move here
this queen g5
is losing a tempo so in this position i
should again just just play knight f6
here
by playing queen g5 i'm allowing a move
knight f3
when he played this move i immediately
realized wait a minute
i i cannot take on g2 because if i take
on g2 he plays king e2
suddenly the knight on f3 is protected
and he is threatening rook a2 g1
okay and now he plays rook a2 g1
trapping my queen and unfortunately i'm
completely stuck now
i am completely stuck here and i'm not
sure what to do
so i couldn't take this and immediately
i realize
i immediately realized that i'm in
trouble here
okay all right can you guys say
something in the chat i want to make
sure i can see the
chat i haven't been seeing any comments
so if you watching say something so i
just want to make sure
i can see the chat guys okay
so i couldn't take it okay i couldn't
take it and immediately i was like ah
i was regretting this because i
have to waste the move to come back
i play queen f6 now he castles and now
i can't even castle because h7 is under
attack
so i have to play now uh knight b6
i'm hoping to get bishop f5 in but i'm
like a move behind here
i'm like really a move behind here if i
can get bishop f5 here i should be okay
but i'm not able to do that
unfortunately so he goes e4
i take he takes
he opens up the position which is
absolutely correct because
i my king is stuck in the middle and i
can i can cancel here again still
because of that h7 pawn hanging
so i play g6 because now i
shut down the diagonal and again
again it's all about that one move here
if i have a choice to go castle
then i'm absolutely fine okay my
position is very reasonable but
uh gareth is a very strong player so
he's not just gonna let me
uh castle that easily so he plays a very
strong move queen c5
activating his queen and now
stopping my king now now i'm stuck in
the middle of the board
and this looks like a very very
dangerous moment here
very very dangerous moment here guys
so what do you think i should do here
how should i um respond here
because i can't keep my king in the
middle too long
you know i mean it's going to go here
he's going to go here and open up the
position so i can't really
keep there too long
so what can i do here
so what can we do here guys
i have to prevent him from castling
again i was very very close guys very
close in this championship i actually
finished second place here
so i decided that the only way i can try
to continue is to play
i go queen e7 here
trying to trade trying to trade
sorry
excuse me guys okay
queen e7 now he played rook fe1
bishop e6
trying to get the development and now he
plays knight g5
and i'm under a lot of pressure oh boy
the knight is activated
the knight is activated on g5 and it
looks like
yeah knight is activated and
what am i gonna do now it looks like i'm
in really big trouble here again
he's got the advantage here guys i want
i want this game but it was it was very
tough game
it was very tough game here i was
defending for much of a game
now the question is what should i do
here
now what should i do here
so
if he um yeah i can't castle
and you know i'm sort of stuck here i
don't have that much
that many options here so i have to i
have to trade
i have to go for it now it takes
attacking my
knight
knight d7 knight d7 now putting pressure
on c5
now he goes b4
trying to defend
now he's trying to defend the c5 pawn
and now i play long castle
trying to run away run away to safety
here
but now he plays bishop f3 bishop f3 and
again the threat is knight takes e6
and very difficult for me to defend this
position
so i decided that okay i should try to
give up the h7 pawn
and try to
look for a contra play the other option
i had here was
to play this move rook d e8
but i didn't like that because my rook
is just too passive here
so bishop g4
takes stakes and f7 is under attack
and if i play f6 then knight f7
very very unpleasant
i mean i can take take
rookie seven
okay some advantage still but
you know i mean definitely an advantage
for him
so so what i did was here guys
i decided okay i'm gonna give up the
pawn but bring my rook into the game now
he takes
and i go f6 at least for a moment
his knight looks kind of chopped and
he has to figure out a way to get this
knight back
into the game
now he goes bishop g4 he's trying to
trade the bishops
now he's trying to trade the bishops and
what should i do here if i trade the
bishops
and let's say i take rook
he takes by the way he's got g5 coming
up so his knight is not really going to
be stuck there for too long
if let's say i go here first of all you
can go here and then
suddenly how do i protect how do i
protect
the f6 pawn so i can't
do that properly and if he goes here i
simply go
rook to e7 activating
activating my rook
so i play g5
so that's why i i had to use the move f5
to gain a tempo now he goes back now i
can no longer do much about
the night knight is going to get back
i'm down a pawn right now
but i'm going to try to get some
activity here bishop c4
now i'm getting ready to activate my
knight
via e5 so i would like to play the move
knight e5
putting pressure on f3 okay
he takes rook takes e8
go rook takes e8
now there is also pressure here on a2
so he plays a3
trying to defend everything and the only
way for me to uh
hold at the moment i'm thinking about
just a draw
so i played a5 trying to create
some weaknesses you know a little bit of
weaknesses so i can
you know try to make a draw here
i don't have any ambitions right now my
goal is just to try to make a draw
it goes king h2 and 95
let's get active now
and he takes and i think here he makes a
move that uh
you know it's gonna weaken his pawns
he's not the pawn here so
perhaps you can play knight f knight uh
knight g5
back or even here he could have played
the move knight guy back but when he did
this
i take this is going to get really
really complicated so
knight d3 now you're putting pressure on
f2
and putting pressure on c5
knight g5
and i take on f2 i'm not too concerned
about c5 pawn i think that pawn is
always going to be weak
that's why i want to eliminate the f2
pawn first
plus if i take here there is
there could be a problem with the move
like rook c1 and then i have
my pieces hanging here so like i can go
here
but then it goes knight f7 threatening
knight d6 so
it gets complicated okay
so knight f2 rook c1 he's attacking the
bishop
and i have to do something with the
bishop so i decided to go on a6
this way he cannot play a move like a6
to weaken my position so i thought this
would be okay for me
he goes rook to c3
and that goes back to d3 now i have a
nice target on c5
and i'm thinking about you know some
rook e5
and take he goes h4
trying to fix my weakness and
if he can somehow win this pawn then he
can quickly play h5h6h7 and win
so i cannot afford to lose my g pawn
here
but i go k7 i i want to bring him in
into the game
i didn't want to play rookie 5 because i
was concerned
about this idea knight f7
takes
takes a knight here
and take on g6 okay
and now can't do anything
and i'm in trouble
i mean i probably have to go here
and takes and play something like this
so that's why i i said you know what let
me bring my kink close to g6 so i don't
lose my pawn okay
it's very important so now he he doesn't
have a good plan here
and he's sort of stuck so he decides to
try to perhaps re-maneuver his knight to
f4
i go rookie five rookie five now putting
pressure on c5
kn g3
and i call knight takes c5
now i'm happy i got my pawn back
and he plays king f4 um trying to
remember what i was planning to do
against knight f4 because
this move makes lots of sense yeah i
think i see it now
i think this is a problem i have i have
maybe some check
um i have a check
and now if it takes
rook takes e4 okay
and now i have some rook g4 idea
if he takes i have this
yeah so but again knight f4 would have
been a very interesting choice but he
played king f4
king d6 defending
now he plays knight g5 if we play king
g5 then i'll have 94
check take now my e3 is there so he has
to go back
and we get into some position like this
which i think
objectively is just just equal here
but i think he's still trying to play
for a win here
so he goes knight g5 back
now he's threatening some knight f7
but i just simply go to key seven now
everything is stopped
i don't think he made any progress and i
now managed to win his pawn
back palms are equal and i think right
around here he started
to lose the trend of the game a little
bit because
here he should have tried to play for a
draw already because
i mean his pawns are weaker
and at some point there might be a risk
for him
but he continued uh with h5 i took
king takes f5 and now
i need to activate the bishop bishop has
been sitting on a6 it's time to bring
him into the game
by the way now he had to go back here
there's a cute idea if he goes here
we have a mate okay
so
yeah now we have a mate
so that's why he cannot go here he goes
back
and i go bishop g6 like i say it's like
i say it's very important okay
it's it's it's very very important
it's very important to keep the h pawn
okay
it's it's it's it it's very important to
keep the h pawn
uh all right so now he plays king g3
now he's trying to bring the king to h4
he's trying to bring the king to h4
and now very important moment here
what should i try to do here very very
important moment
very important moment because we want to
try to trade okay
we want to try to trade and simplify the
position
you know if he goes k4 then i have to
worry about him trying to win my h-pawn
at the moment
i'm already i already know that i'm
probably equal here at least
okay so here i played 94
check very important move
now trading pieces he has to trade at
this one and i take
if he goes now bishop takes h5 then i go
check he goes here i take and
i mean it's probably going to be a draw
but i'm the only one who can play
because his a pawns are weak
most likely it's going to be a drawdow
but he didn't want to do this
he i think still thought he can maybe
play so he plays king h4
and now it's getting closer and closer
for him
to get into trouble i take rook takes
perhaps again taking with the pawn would
have been a little bit better because
now he takes
and now very important move here i don't
want to play
rook to e5 because then i'm going to be
running into this idea and
yeah basically a draw
like i said at the moment i'm not
playing for a draw anymore
so i play here and i think he might have
underestimated this one because now
it's becoming clear that if he plays a
move like uh rook
a5 i push
he trades he's not in a square
he's not in the square to stop my pawn
so i will be winning okay
so i will be winning now
so let's go back
so i play rook h7 and now he played a4
and now k5 centralizing my king
and now i'm getting ready to push my c
pawn my rook is doing a fantastic job
here
protecting h pawn and a b-pawn and here
i think he's getting
into a big trouble here maybe he can
still make a draw here but
he has to play very precisely which he
didn't he played g3
c5
he probably thought he can never lose
this position but now changes six
nice losing now he goes here and now a
very important move very important move
here
because one thing we know from the rook
end games right guys
we have to put the rook behind
the past pawn always remember you got a
passport
you got to put the rook behind it and
there is no difference here
we go here he takes we push now
threatening c
c2 and now king here
king c3 and here he resigned because he
realized he is like
way behind in this race because i go
here let's say he goes here
i promote
and he is many many moves behind
not even one or two yeah i just
by the time he promotes yeah it's all
about having that one extra pawn
and he cannot stop it
so after the move king d4 uh i think
king c3 yeah i think he played here king
c3 he resigned here
so this was a critical win for me guys
because as i mentioned
i wasn't doing too well in a tournament
i had a lot of draws
okay so i wasn't happy with but now this
was a breakthrough moment because after
this game
i won three more games okay
i want three more games so i had four
consecutive victories in a row
okay and then i was leading the u.s
championship
for for with one point and uh
i lost one game to sam shankland and
that would cost me the
championship in round uh
i won round six seven eight round nine i
lost that game yeah
and then that that being that being very
costly
uh okay so but yeah this this
this shows how how difficult sometimes
things can be
how difficult things can be and
you have to always try to make the right
decision he he definitely overplayed his
his his position here
you know he had very good winning
chances earlier when i made a mistake in
opening
but he played with that flow that you
know he's you know he still has to try
to play for a win
and that's a big risk right there okay
it's a very big risk if you keep playing
for a win in a position that you
shouldn't
then it's possible that that's gonna
cost you
okay so that's possible that that might
cost you
so all right
and now we're gonna look at the next
game okay
so i hope you guys enjoyed this game and
this is the game got if against me 2014
u.s championship
you can find uh you know you can find
this game very easily and
look in more details okay uh
let me let me actually this is not what
i need
yeah this is the game now the same
tournament
uh i'm playing ray robson and again
ray uh was already very very strong in
2014 he's 26
31 so i'm playing with the black pieces
and we always have this french defense
battles with ray
back and forth i think he won a few
games i won some games
so when i'm playing him i know he's
gonna play e4
but suddenly he opens up with d4
which comes up as a huge surprise
because you know previously he had
scored some good
good wins against me i scored some wins
as well
but you know i didn't expect him to play
d4 being myself as a d4 player
so i was happy to see it but he has a
specific
preparation catalan
so he probably prepared this with his
friend or second
so he was playing quite fast here so i
went check bishop d2 bishop p7
and now i played c6 i decided to play a
very solid setup
knight bd7 bishop f4
so we repeat it uh but
then i went back to see if he wants but
no he he wants to play for a win
and uh i don't know how he was doing at
that point at that point
i was already on a plus two score so
draw it black wouldn't be bad so now he
just goes knight bd2 and he wants to
play e4
very simply wants to play four so i say
okay i have to play b6
so he plays b3 so basically white has
two options here
okay white has two options he can play
for
e4 here or you can play for the b3 plan
they're both playable if he plays here i
was probably
i was planning to kick he takes bishop
b7
and we played this position
bishop f4 perhaps i can play c5
and it's it's a game
it's a game here
so
let's go back i place b3
i go bishop to b7
bishop b2
and now i play rook c because i'm
getting ready to play c5
okay c1 i wasn't so sure i thought maybe
he should
consider this setup here uh since he
didn't play four right away if he plays
e4 here it's
it's a bit too slow you know it's bit
too slow
i have c5 and putting pressure okay
so i played here i play c5
queen b8 and
i thought you know the rook on c1 would
have been maybe better so he plays here
now i take
i want to open up my light square bishop
he takes back with the
knight bishop e4 queen a1
and i take i just want to equalize the
game for now
so he takes me to bishop um
another idea he can do here is rook
takes d4
but then i go queen c7 doubles rook rook
ft1
and okay a lot of exchanges occur and
looks like just just equal position here
okay
so he didn't want to just trade
everything with the white pieces and
make a draw
so ray usually never plays for a draw so
i knew that it's going to be a big fight
here
especially he's like probably a point
behind me or
something so he's going to try to beat
me so i go queen c7 now
i'm trying to play rook fd8 okay now i'm
trying to go to kfd8
and queen b7 i mean he doesn't have any
advantage here
but you know he's quite ambitious
players so he plays bishop h3
trying to move this bishop and now
some knight g5 ideas coming up so i go
to cafe
trying to see what is what does he have
look 2 c1
now remember in opening i mentioned he
should have maybe played rook ac1 right
away because now
he's sort of losing a little tempe now i
go back queen b7 and now he goes knight
g5
this is very concrete but unfortunately
it doesn't work
i have very very good defense here
bishop c6
queen b1
and um he's
he's definitely putting a lot of
pressure there's pressure here
so there's a lot of ideas he has but i
have this knight on fa which is i think
a very important move
it's because now h7 is guarded and e6 is
guarded so he cannot really
uh sacrifice anything and when i do this
ah i remember now
the key thing is now the bishop is
hanging which is a very huge
for me because otherwise he was going to
be able to play 95
but here he can't because i will simply
pick up
the bishop on d4
so
all right i played uh
knight f8 and he plays rook fd1
so now he has a monster threat knight e5
here
now here's a monster thread to do that
and now
what should i try to do here
what should i try to do
in this position here because i want to
give you some time to think here okay
so because we know his threats we know
his threats and what should i try to do
to
defend it against his 95 threat
okay let's see here
hello hello everybody greetings
greetings glad to see you all here
yeah that was a tough one i agree with
you adam that was a tough one
all right so what do we do now guys i
mean we're playing another very tough
competitor ray robson here
uh why is 95 a threat that's a good
question
why is 95 at threat let me show you
because he goes here he attacks this and
he attacks
this he's gonna have too many threats
okay
so that's that's why okay
so what is the idea here what can i do
guys
bishop before i don't think so i don't
want to lose
i don't want to lose my light square
bishop
night is very active don't you think
it's maybe time to question this night
maybe it's time we question this night
yeah and push him away
can we question him
knight g6 is an idea too so
h6 absolutely let's question that knight
now he cannot sacrifice anything i mean
if he sacks here
he could but it just doesn't work
i go here he goes here
it it just doesn't work because like
if it takes i take bishop g2 i can take
rook c1
and it tries to do this
he goes here pinning
okay so that's the problem
so after h6 he had to go here
i need to plug it one second my laptop
okay sorry i forgot to plug it so
okay all right guys sorry about that so
now we take
take and guess what we give up we gave
up our
bishop so we have to take that extra
pawn
you know because if we give about a
strong light score bishop we better take
it
okay we better take it because otherwise
we're not going to have
a good compensation
so it was 95
attacking my queen and here he probably
thought he has good compensation here
which is very possible but with a very
precise play
slowly i will neutralize that
compensation so he took he could also
play
uh bishop g2 here but
that loses to this tactic rook takes c5
check and we pick up the knight okay so
that would be a blunder
so that's why he had to take uh first on
c8 take
again every trade now is going to bring
me closer
every time i trade it brings me closer
here okay
what do you do here
and now what do i do can you guys find
the move here let's see here let me look
at the chat here to see
all right correct yogi yes knight g4
activating the knight threatening this
and also threatening to take this
absolutely yogi
knight g4 of course yes i won i won four
games in a row and became a clear leader
in this tournament
now he has to trade i mean if he goes
knight f3 back it's just
it's just going to be very passive so
so he takes take now bishop p3 now
the next step is very important here i
need to figure out a way to trade the
dark square
bishop so now i'm
trying to uh harass the bishop like this
to see if we can trade so he attacks me
i go here
now i'm trying to create some dark
square weaknesses
okay bishop here
and now it looks tough here but now a
good move here needed here
i need you to find this good move to pin
him up a little bit okay
you want to pin him up here how can we
do that
we need to pin him up here and
in order to win
absolutely yeah
yeah rook d8 perfect pinning it
absolutely now he plays g4 attacking the
queen
i was very happy to see this because
this is weakening his position
tremendously
he should have done anything else but
that's more because after this now it's
going to be a big problem okay
so this is going to be a big problem for
him so queen d8
bishop e5
okay he's trying to trap me here so i
don't want that so i trade
and b7 now now my queen can retreat
and i want to play knight g6 now knight
j6 and control the dark squares
now i play squinty 2 bishop c5
it's a strong move now applying pressure
here
and now i'm getting ready to get my
knight out
so bishop is very well placed here so
bishop b8
e5 i'm happy to put my bishop here
and i goes queen f3
he's trying to activate his queen here
now what should i do here guys
again my my idea is to try to trade the
bishops here somehow
what do you think is the best move here
well he couldn't attack the queen here
because if he attacks the queen this way
we have a fantastic capture okay
can't do that so here here he goes here
absolutely queen comes back to d8
attacking the bishop
now he goes back here and now we get
active
now we're attacking that bishop again
and now it's i'm very very glad that the
pawn is on g4 here because his dark
squares are going to be very weak
so he goes bishop g3 and again
now how can i try to get that
dark square bishop off the board
how can i do that
well if you go bishop d6 you're gonna
run into queen d3
if you do this the problem is he pins
you and it's not good
and i don't i want to avoid this end
game this end game might be a very good
drawing chances because of the two
bishops
yes okay so i don't want that so
here is the 40th move here is the 40th
move before we make time control
so i really have to play this precisely
here guys
very important
now knight h4 he has queen a8
i don't want him to trade queens now if
he trades queens you might have
decent drawing chances
you need to play logical and active okay
you need to play logical and active here
guys
absolutely queen d2 activating the queen
and also attacking the pawn perfect
now he plays a force and now
what can we do here what can we do
what is the idea here
bishop d6 absolutely
well we're getting very close now guys
now we accomplish another important task
here
trading the bishops so he takes
queen d6 um
if you are wondering why he didn't play
check
here here if you're wondering why he
didn't just do this
okay because now it looks like he's got
me pinned up
if he does that i have i have few
options here but
i was thinking i can do this check
if he goes here now i just take
and i take
take on g3
uh and if he goes to here
then i can even
play move like this and now i
if it takes i can take back with the
knight and i'm also threatening a move
queen f2
which is a which is a huge threat i
don't want to take necessarily because
he takes the f
pawn and he's got some protection i
don't necessarily want to do that
okay now i can take on f2
so
all right so when i did this
he trade and now i have a wonderful
position here guys
knight goes here and now i i
i played this move and now i'm
threatening 92 check
so he checks queen c4
and now g5 a wonderful idea
uh i could take also and play this way
but yeah then i have to go here it's
probably still winning
but i didn't want to even allow this
because
why should i even allow this after g5 he
actually has no moves
white literally cannot move anything
here so
this is an example of a success okay
so he checks i go here
now he has to go here because if he
gives me a check
it's funny actually i go here and now he
doesn't have a defense
against knight h3 because he cannot get
his queen back
i mean b3 pawn is hanging as well
you're seeing a complete domination here
guys
complete domination so
he played here queen e3 but
domination is domination how are we
gonna win the game
that's the question okay
now we're dominating but we still have
to score a victory now
now he is looking at the eyeballing this
pawn maybe
so what should we do here
but although if he takes we have a
knight h3 threat so it's not a
not a big big issue there
but yeah i also don't want to move my
knight because my knight is well placed
on f4
so yeah
knight d5 he will probably play
something like
queen d3 let's say
yeah taking f8 now it goes before now
actually
the reason i play king f8 is
he doesn't have any moves because i kind
of passed a turn to him
and then he started to think he realized
there's no moves
so please freeze for a second here to
understand and appreciate
this position here suk sawang
right here okay white is in the serious
suksawang guys he
is in a serious success
what do you think we can do here guys
king f8 absolutely yes
absolutely that's what i played here i
play king f8
and he has no moves he has no moves
whatsoever guys he has absolutely no
moves here
he goes here
because if it takes
that loses to check
here check and position is falling apart
you cannot move the king away we take on
f1 so
i mean if he plays f3 we have knight
takes h3
so yeah it's unclear
so that's why you play b4 but again this
this cannot work
i took queen takes a four because now i
want to be able to take the second pawn
uh other moves as well win
i mean this is a win too but i have to
calculate things i didn't even want to
calculate
so so here
i take he played
b5 he's trying to close the position and
he's hoping that he can get the b6 pawn
but here i'm not going to give him the
b6 pawn here
now i have a wonderful pawn on a5
uh h4 where uh sorry h the question is
h4
or here uh h4
uh the problem is you're dropping this
guy
and then you're dropping the h4 pawn
great wolf
so now he played b5 here and he's trying
to take
he's trying to take on b6
i don't want to give him that pawn
i you know maybe i could do it but of
course 95 is a great move defending it
and attacking
now he's trying to get active with queen
to e5
and now time to activate our queen
time to activate our queen guys
queen f4 check
queen takes h6
i don't mind losing that pawn because
now i'm gonna go after the f2 pawn
if two pawn is really weak and i'm gonna
go after the f2 pawn how
because my king is very safe he doesn't
have any more checks
so it's time for me to go for some more
activity here
knight
knight to c3 because now i'm threatening
knight e4
and after knight e4 it's gonna be a
disaster for him i just take
so he plays here bishop g2
now
what can we do here yeah i could also
push the a pawn i agree with you there
are many ways to win here
but you you want to choose one concrete
plan and just go with it
okay so i chose this plan here
now we need to attack f2 here guys
knight d1 correct
there were other moves as well 92 is
winning
and then mate on g1 yeah that was too
bad i just wanted to stay with my plan
now it goes f3
now what do we do
queen e3 check king h1
and now knight goes back to c3 the
reason i went back knight c3 because now
i just want to go here and it's just
wonderful and i'm threatening mate on g1
so you can't do anything the king is
gonna get mated
he has to be very quick so he goes here
and now he goes here
and now i push the a pawn because the
queen
cannot move anywhere
so he can take
because of the mate
so he played h4 he's trying to
it's a last hop but there is really no
hope here
yeah well we made the bishop bad we made
him to be passive
by constantly threatening
uh what are we gonna do now
what we're gonna do opponent is very
strong ray robson guys very strong
grandmaster
so it's just happened to be a really
good game i took
now i placed g5 now again he's trying to
do some queen f6
check and here i was like okay
i can maybe even allow that check but
don't want to do that
so let me just find the simplest way to
win this game
simplest and don't give opponent any
chances okay you want to give opponent
zero chances
zero chances okay what is the idea that
will give him
zero chances
you know you never want to get too fancy
okay
i mean maybe queen g1 but i don't i
don't need that i don't need to suck a
piece yeah
if we don't need to if we don't have to
we don't want to sack it
yeah queen c1 check
and if it goes up we just take the queen
if it takes we go here
and he resigned because now
i mean okay he can he can if he really
wants he can bring this here and sack
the bishop but
he resigned because there's just
absolutely no hope here
so after i played queen c1 he just
resigned here
so yeah this was another very important
victory okay
another very important victory in a u.s
championship against ray robson
again guys this was a there was a quiet
game but there were some very critical
moments here i want to go back again
to the middle middle point new game
where
you know i i had to find some tough
moves
i tell you this i mean here
things are not that easy i i i i
i finished second place that year kamsky
won
so i i lost the tie break to him for the
title
uh yeah this this is the moment here
because he plays queen b1 and
i remember it took me some time to find
this move because he does have some
activity okay
he does have some activity so it's not
like uh
you know he's not doing anything so i
mean this was a very important move
knight f8 and hitting the bishop okay
knight f8 and we are attacking the
bishop on d4
rook ft1 h6
and we take and frame here on it's still
not so simple but
we start trading pieces off and slowly
win but again
i had to find some very tough moves here
guys
you know in this position knight f8
a bishop c6 retreat knight f8
and then when he still wants to go
knight e5
i have h6 okay
i think he nakamura didn't play that
years he didn't play that year
so all right very good guys
now i prepared a couple of positions for
you to work on today
so we'll do those uh to finish up with
okay
so i hope you guys enjoyed this games
and let's get to those positions
position number one
wide to play and win
we will have couple of positions here
today
white to play and that's a silent move
we're going to work on the topic called
a silent move
okay where you need to find that silent
move idea to win the game
so what do we do
where we have a pawn on the seventh rank
but we're not sure
we're not sure how to push it we're not
sure how to promote it
okay
rook c1 i think he plays d3
plays d3 and if you play rook c8 he
plays d2
you queen and he plays d1 mate so
all right yeah i never tried the chinese
chest or shogi but
yeah looks looks interesting all right
let's think a little bit guys let's
think before you make suggestions okay
it's very important here to find the
correct move
you have to see about four moves deep
here because
you have to see about four moves deep
here to get to the
winning advantage okay
rook f7 what is the plan you say rook f7
what is the plan after d7 though d3
war is the plan here guys
rookie eight
d2 woof oof it looks complicated
now he's threatening d1
rookie 5 doesn't work guys rookie 5 he
can just take king takes e5
if you were doing rookie 5 he just takes
with a king
okay you guys you guys need to think a
little bit deeper okay
all right rookie 8 d2 and now
this actually i don't know if you guys
guessed it but this was the correct
uh correct line
now you have a very nice move check
text check
and we're gonna take the d2 pawn
absolutely absolutely okay and you're
gonna pick it up
perfect all right
so he goes here that was the correct
idea
so once again silent move this is a game
between two very strong russian grand
masters
rook f7 d3 rookie 8
d2 it's hard to find i know
it's hard to find that's why i'm showing
you guys not easy stuff here next one
a couple of more for you prepared for
today about
four four positions total this is
position number two white to play
all right white to play what is the
winning plan here for white
uh that game was played uh kishma thulin
versus matlakov kish methulen matlakov
game
now what to do here guys
very important moment what to do
look v8 be careful guys if you go to p8
there is a rook a1 check
you might be in big trouble here
we need to figure out which square is
weak
this one right this is a huge square
here huge weak square here right
knight d5 threatening knight f6
now he can take because his queen is
under attack
so if he goes here
then what do you do
how do we set up the mating net here
guys
check animate
and you cannot do anything okay
so knight d5 the other option left
is queen takes d6
but if he does that what do you do guys
check if he goes up we have a mate
queen h6 mates if he goes to
take sorry if he goes here
then we have made in two here
you see it right made in two guys
what is the mating tool
yeah queen h8 and 28 correct
so that leaves me with the only option
to take and if it takes
we have a mating net on
h8 okay
cannot stop it the only other option
left is if you place rook a5
because now if you play knight f6
he wants to do this this and rook h5 he
has this idea
okay
but we don't have to do that we can
start with another move here
we don't have to play always knight f6
we can do another move here
yeah bishop f6 now threatening queen h8
mate
if he takes knight f6 check picking up
all right and that's a mate so that's
the winning
idea guys again silent move quiet move
okay
don't always think the tactic is gonna
work sometimes you need to
quiet maneuvering move okay like knight
d5 here
to win the chess game alright
alright then i have one more position
here oops
okay
all right block to play and win
oops
block to play and win here guys
this is not a very difficult position so
i think you will find this
it's just a calculation pure calculation
here okay
i'll calculate a little bit more
calculate a little bit more guys
what the what's going to happen if you
push the pump right
yeah we can push the pound but what's
what's going to happen
yeah so if he goes here
oops i gotta stop this
sorry all right
so if he goes here it's easy we just
check
and we bring this in
so that that that we can eliminate but
we have to calculate two options bishop
f2
one option and the king h1
if he plays bishop f2 then what do you
do
so we take attacking the rook
now he goes here and it looks like he's
gonna take on c2
but what move we're going to play here
so we don't allow that
yeah rook t8 and now threatening group
d1
check takes
check and take
check and take
all right so bishop f2 doesn't work what
if he plays king h1
now we take now he goes here
it looks like he's gonna take now but a
very very strong move here we have guys
very very strong move we have
yeah rook 88 threatening rook d1
so he takes i take
now he goes here rook e1
rook d1 check if he takes we promote
into a queen he goes here and now which
rook you're gonna take
very important which rook you're going
to take
because if you take the wrong rook it's
not going to work
yes e1 takes and
finishing move bishop e3 perfect
absolutely you have to do it this way if
you do it any other way it's not gonna
work okay
all right perfect again always look for
discovery check
always look for the background checks
okay
when opponent is in a situation like
this always he's gonna have background
ideas
and the last position guys for today
block to play and you need to play like
anish giri a very strong play by
anishkiri it looks like
very messy position here but giri found
this
maneuver and after which he's just
simply winning
block to play and you have to play like
anishkiri i think it's against shirov
i think this was against alex ishirov
black to play and win
uh-huh bishop f2 he can take
bishop f2 he can take you need to be
careful
bishop f2 he takes
and he goes here
check actually you could even lose
correct move is bishop g1 yes because
now you're threatening mate
okay it's amazing idea
now he doesn't have a check on a f8 you
take only 8 is covered everything is
covered
so he has to play h4 because now he's
trying to get a hiding square for the
king on h3
now what do you do then
no no no no not bishop f2 please think
no you can't go rook h2 he's gonna start
checking you
we need to figure out the transfer
transfer that bishop to a better
position
okay bishop h2 bishop h2 correct
now he goes here bishop d6 and now
we are threatening a mate on h2
now if he goes here now you got a maiden
three here can you see it
now mate in three check
king up
check up
now what's the mate
yep 24 mate perfect bravo bravo
excellent
good job guys excellent work today
so this was some very good silent move
positions for you see
bishop is looks active here but really
need to transfer it to a better square
okay
that's why we do that bishop here
threatening mate
check very hard maneuver this check
somebody suggested this check the
problem is he takes
and if you check he goes rook f3 and
it gets really complicated so we don't
want that okay
there's no mate here so it's complicated
so that's why we just go check
very straightforward and here and thread
check
all right all right excellent great job
everyone thank you everybody for
watching these two lectures
uh from the u.s championship 2014
and uh i will be also streaming on the
uh sunday so make sure you tune in
and saturday i have a simultaneous
exhibition okay
so check out this weekend schedule so
you will see me online this saturday and
sunday okay
thank you for watching and we'll see you
soon again guys hope you enjoyed it
take care